[Musique]
quelle est la première chose dont tu te souviens feu
comment t'appelles-tu Kristen bienvenue dans le
Seigneur ta nouvelle maison pourquoi suis-je ici
tu ne peux pas leur faire dire quoi que ce soit
parfois je ils emmènent les gens ils
ne reviennent pas  Si j'étais toi, je ferais
attention à la nouvelle fille, il y a un fantôme ici, je suis
sûr que tu crois que tu as vu ce que tu as dit,
je ne suis pas fou, elle est la dernière à
sortir, elle était l'une d'entre nous, mais elle est partie
maintenant.  et maintenant elle va nous tuer tout
ce que vous avez à faire avec lui nous devons
sortir d'ici
[Musique]
ce n'était pas si mal, n'est-ce pas